I think india will become one of the
leading economic superpowers the 21st
century just behind China actually think
india will catch up with china growth
rate on infrastructure would growth rate
within the next three to five years i
think the danger for india is it becomes
complacent and the rising indian shining
india story makes the establishment
business political terms too complacent
self-satisfied because there's a
tendency for the Indians to think that
everything is mine and they're going to
worry about the rest of the world I
think the truth is that India showing
under the leadership with Adam Sharma
the new commerce minister and that it
wants to engage in the Jews money on the
Doha round by mr. Singh is taking his
rightful place on climate control other
issues in the Copenhagen Hawks i think
india will become a responsible and more
important with layer in the g20 which
will be the new global directorate for
economic policy setting so whether
Gideon will become a superpower define
superpower is among the fastest-growing
strongest economies on the planet in the
21st century yes militarily no although
it is a nuclear member of another
hundred cleared them but let's call it
Roman superpower let's call it one of
the top three economic players of the
funny for a century